did you go cat uh nope i went back home
oh you went homecap yeah i visited my
family again what's going on with him
in vietnam uh no i did facetime or
weird monk in vietnam because my mom
says that he could predict the future
uh he didn't say anything about that he
said that i need to pray more
and that i had a lover in the past life
who's haunting me now and that's why i'm
single oh my god
wow i could totally see that [ __ ] yeah
sorry i'm sorry how do you you don't
know that right uh
shirtless slightly overweight and he's
speaking in tongues yes
oh well it sounds like he was missed his
bike trip and so yeah
sounds like he needs to get on a bike it
all sounds like he was
pitching his shot against you he has to
see your feet
no but i did have to stand up and he had
to see like my full body in order to do
that oh yeah
so i was like in a sweater he has a
metoo movement coming any day now it
sounds like
uh i think it'll take about five years
for it to get out there
in vietnam yeah and did um and what
who who recommended you do this kind of
thing is this like a regular occurrence
is this what's
my mom yes your mom talks to him all the
time uh not him all the time but anytime
somebody has to
do anything with like spiritual videos
people kind of yeah okay wow she's into
that
she loves it and so why was your mom
like oh let's call this guy this is why
you're singing because she cares about
it
because she cares about her daughter
brendan yeah i think it makes her feel
better that's easy to me
as long as he thinks i'll be fine like
i'll be fine your mom's like that makes
sense
what's his name carl i have no idea
carl's
car let's call him mon yeah that's
yeah he spoke in tongues he was over how
did you understand no i didn't
understand there was a translator there
holy [ __ ] so he had a translator with
that they do it to your sister too
yeah and apparently my sister is going
to live a very hard life
do you think he would zoom in at some
point maybe he might
can you but can we need a translator
right his translator i think travels
with him all the time
so that's okay he's balling he might be
able to do something let's make that
happen no yeah
it'd
and i'm gonna go out on a limb here and
you can stop me if you want chappelle
but i will be out on this limb if you
need to go ahead
in the urban community and that's a
that is a racial generalization or the
dark chinese
some people refer to a black culture uh
say on like mystics and seances you guys
get more scared of that kind of stuff
did your oh yeah
that's just yeah freaky i mean but you
get yeah i think in new orleans or
whatever
dark they don't they do like the voodoo
yeah yeah
heavy isn't it like oh it's more popular
down there
yeah when i was growing up there was
always you know mystics running around
you know
rain sticks we had a lady used to be a
rib reader she would read your ribs and
read the side of your body oh i like
that
and uh crap huh yeah like a map like a
bone map
oh wow um but i always had my black
friends would always get scared if
somebody came around with a ouija board
or somebody came around with a hit of
acid or something you know
so your family does it all the time sad
uh every now and then i actually okay
sorry i was talking to chappelle
sorry guys she was texted the guy okay
my bad
i'm sorry video of it i know there's
still a video of me oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] i'm trying to air drop it to him
right now now back to
black people there's a lot of black
people doing it in
louisiana there's there were not a lot
of people there was more fear of that
kind of stuff yeah
they were scared of it got it what do
you think
yeah i'm scared of that [ __ ] yeah you
know there's a comic that that started
doing the readings you know thomas dale
yeah yeah he does like those uh readings
everyone says it's like
you can get him in here oh we could
thomas dale does it he's a clairvoyant
any and he's gay yeah oh i love him yeah
he's a beast he's a beast he's fully gay
he's great he's a great comic he's good
at
com comedy and reading people's minds
and [ __ ] well that's awesome
well we'll figure that out we'll be the
judge of that i'm telling you the second
part can be drug-induced
and no offense i hopefully it is you
know you don't want to meet a shaman
that's never freaking hit a rock you
know
i don't believe in it but i'd love to
have him in here but no he's
so funny man it's really is he he's that
would be great that'd be great
he does it he does i think he does it
through zoom and stuff oh that's kind of
a bomber
but that's how he's doing it right here
his cat right here
that's my mom uh holding up the phone
and beautiful you guys look alike huh
uh yeah i look just actually i look more
like my dad but
that's what he looks like why is his
shirt up i don't know that's money oh
that's money he's a little kid is he 14
yeah
i think he is like
17 or whoa between the age of 17 to like
20.
oh apparently he he's had this ability
since he was a kid
you ever seen that kid on e the the the
super gay boy yeah who like goes to
kardashians and stuff
yeah and he met with robin thicke like
three months before yeah i was like oh
you have a heart problem rom thinks like
no i don't he's like i'm telling you to
get checked out
bam three months later he died heart
attack the kid did
no no robin the kid called it how robin
thicke was 200 years old dude i couldn't
tell you that three months later though
and then you saw the kardashians right
robin thicke
robin thicke robin fix the singer yeah
well no no no
no his dad his dad dude allen allen dick
i was like wait robin thinks a lot
about allen thing throbbing thick dude
that guy
couldn't handle robin you got a brand
doug
oh and this guy's young is that him
that's him that's a little yeah this guy
goes around town this guy seems reliable
hey i trust him i trust him more than
cat's
14 year old that speaks in your tongue
with a shirt off
bro really you're gonna trust a 14 year
old been some freaking drug twink that's
been out here
running around the hollywood hills
predicting that celebrities are going to
die soon no [ __ ] it's been right though
a lot of times they all die
anything on e is complete [ __ ]
brendan you know that
yeah i did work with him i did two times
that was awesome yeah
yeah i mean a lot of it is just it's not
stuff i
i would way more believe cat who's from
a seance area
vietnam dude than somebody else like
that little white kid
the fourteen-year-old kid only speaks
with his tits out
i mean is there anything more spiritual
than that though yeah his titties are
out
why does he have a shirt off because he
doesn't need a shirt like this freaking
rich [ __ ]
yeah well he's rich because he's right
about it no he isn't he does live shows
i'm telling you go
go to the allen thick one it's
mind-blowing there he is
he died yeah oh it's going to be
something that we really have to keep in
mind
i love him now heart issues that happen
to men it's not uncommon but the thing
is
is that uh let me see what that is
how good is like a good and then he
takes a piece of paper
and he's like you know what you're gonna
have a heart attack go get it checked
out
that's why i tip my hat and leave the
show
nothing i tip it with you thank you
brother amen we're in on the 14 year old
who
zoom calls everybody hey yeah i trust
that yeah i trust that comic
oh thomas yeah yeah let's get thomas in
here whoa
uh let's all i i love thomas is thomas a
good
seancer i don't know i don't think it's
called seance
i don't know he's a medium yeah he's a
media
let's let's see he there's a he he
offers it on his ig let's see what he's
saying here
yeah there we go yeah how could you not
trust that with the pony
this is also usually he's eating a bowl
of bowl and now we're taking it away
for september uh august is fully booked
so we are done
sold out wow september is now open if
you want to have a reading with me
a medium or a clairvoyant session reach
out to me dm me now and book that slot
it's 60 bucks for 45 to 50 minutes or if
you just want to try a little starter
session
see what it's like it's 25 bucks for 20
minutes
okay
i will get in touch with them he's got
i've had something
so amazing for me and the people i've
been reading everybody's just been
completely loving it and it definitely
helps put you on a new path i will give
you the insight that you might need
uh leave a review down at the bottom at
the comments
should i send my money now and it was
like well let's all
do it what are the pricing again can you
go back to the pricing area it was 25
for 20 minutes 60 for
45 to an hour can we get how much for
four people
i'd like to get nick and chin in there
too so i want to
hear the pricing again i don't trust you
guys as recollection of the price
was it 49.99 or if you just want to try
a little shout out to me dm me now and
book that slot
it's 60 bucks for 45 to 50 minutes or if
you just want to try a little starter
session
see what it's like it's 25 bucks for 20
minutes
okay you have some spirits you want to
hit up a minute
a dollar a minute i agree look i'm all
for it i i would love to get thomas in
here and discuss the future and the past
at the same time everyone
everyone i talked to has loved it oh
yeah who's everybody
like i've known like five people to do
it oh yeah that sounds vague
okay super audrey stewart ally mikowski
did it gabby lama did it my friend
ashoka thomas did it
um who else did it um some other some
more white people
you know a bunch of white people i don't
know if any yeah this is what we need to
do then we need to have a seance off we
need to have cat sky versus thomas dale
fighting yeah yes
that's a battle you know what i'm saying
let's have that lamp rub and see these
bad boys get at it
dude i say we get that lava lamp in the
middle and have these boys go at it oh
no yeah
have them go out i'll tell you what they
look up chin's dark past ski you're
pretty weird up in here i know they're
scary you're open to it i would in the
past yeah but the future i don't want to
know
the past you can look into it as much as
you want god bless you for that well you
already know the point
i'm the same way i'm with you you guys
don't know
and so i don't want to be too heavy here
but this is kind of heavy
so i had a friend that passed away last
year you know this
cat his mother was very much into this
stuff as well she's vietnamese she said
from the
from childhood uh he would pass away
by the time he's 39 years old we were
with him on his birthday for his 39th
birthday and he passed away
a day and a half afterwards did the mom
say this yeah and you believe so
i mean that's so freaking you know nail
like
do you think she's telling them so much
honor though the whole family knew it
that's why she kept praying during the
time
honor your mother that much to die when
she wants you to i did
nothing there's nothing braver really
well there's nothing really yeah
i'm scared to listen to the future song
yeah no i don't need i i don't want it
y'all can do it yeah some of you guys no
i don't want anyone yeah they're
they're my i see i see on a bike next
year having a heart attack
yeah your future is easy to predict
that's why i'm going to save my money i
feel like yours is pretty easy to
predict too
yeah what being a dang western hero
brendan hey
i salute to thank you brother i
appreciate that i like tombstone up in
this [ __ ]
yeah i dude i like tombstone pizza yeah
dang i don't know if i'd do it either
now now i'm kind of nervous
chin dropped that dark face
your whole family believes in there
right or yes your mom it's my whole
family
so it's pretty pretty can you change the
like if he's like listen if you're going
at the rate you're going
no 400 pounds i'm ready to ride that
smoke bro i'm ready to know you ain't
scared and you do it on you'll do it on
the episode
yeah i'll get read out on the episode
dude
oh we could do it for patreon but see
here's the thing about thomas thomas
doesn't
like um predict the future no he's not
going to tell your future it's like
i want my [ __ ] he just knows about
like uh recipes
oh what'd you say good spirits like come
to him
and say what i don't know i haven't done
it yet we have all these friends dude
you're vouching for him
yeah you have all these friends that are
winning the lottery all of a sudden yeah
all these struggling comics they all
sent him the next day chappelle
yeah all five of you yeah we gave him 60
bucks
you look like threat michael's michaels